alors voilà on est une bande de voleurs
quand on joue à ça
on est amené à se faire des ennemis
et il arrive parfois que nos ennemis
reviennent pour se venger
pour tout dire
on a aidé qu'il fallait pas à voler ce
qu'il fallait pas
on pensait pas libéré la plus grande
force maléfique que le monde ait connu
mais on va arranger ça d'accord et
comment on va faire
on en discute autour d'un verre pas bête
yoni pour avoir une chance de gagner on
aura besoin de forces tu va assurer un
baume y est si on compte sur toi
on aura aussi besoin de courage de magie
et de toi
c'est quoi déjà ce truc une ourse ebooks
merci
on les garde
le mal règne ici
je suis contente qu'il soit avec nous
cet homme est dangereux
mais quoi qu'il arrive
on sera prêt
c'est quoi exactement tall planificateur
c'est moi qui fait les plans qu'il a
déjà fait le plein si le plan qui était
prévu foire je refais un plan d'eau que
tu fais des plans qui foirent bon et il
joue aussi du luth c'est pas le sujet
[Musique]